LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
SILENCE YOUR CELL PHONE AND
MOBILE DEVICES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.>>>
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
TODAY WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO BE
HEARING A TIMELY ADDRESS ABOUT
THE EUROPEAN UNION DELIVERED BY
AUSTRIAN PRESIDENT DR. VAN DER
BELLEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK DR. JACK
SNYDER FOR MODERATING  THE
QUESTION AND ANSWER PERIOD THAT
WILL FOLLOW THE PRESIDENT'S
REMARKS.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUSTRIAN OFFICIALS WHO ARE
TRAVELING TODAY WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO
COLUMBIA.>>> I HAVE NOTICED
SOMETHING OF A TREND AMONG THE
WORLD LEADERS WE ARE WELCOMING
TO COLUMBIA THIS WEEK.
SEVERAL WERE ACADEMICS BEFORE
ENTERING POLITICS.
EXPERIENCE THAT IN THIS FORM WE
BELIEVE IS IDEAL.
FOR DECADES BEFORE ENTERING
POLITICS HE LIVED AND WORKED IN
ACADEMIC COMMUNITIES HAVING
MUCH IN COMMON WITH THIS ONE.
HE SERVED THE UNIVERSITY OF
VIENNA AS THE DEAN OF FACULTY
OF SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC SCIENCES
AND PRIOR TO THAT, HE WAS A
NOTED ECONOMIST AND FACULTY
MEMBER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
INNSBRUCK.
HE IS A NATURALIZED AUSTRIAN
CITIZEN AND SELF DESCRIBED
CHILD OF REFUGEES.
HIS FAMILY WAS DISPLACED TWICE
FROM RUSSIA IN 1919 AND THEN
FROM ESTONIA IN 1940.
HE HAS EXPRESSED HIS GRATITUDE
FOR OUR SHIVER BEING THE
COUNTRY THAT PROVIDED A SAFE
HARBOR AND THEN A HOME FOR HIS
FAMILY.
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN POLITICS
IN 1994 WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO
PARLIAMENT AS A MEMBER OF
AUSTRIA'S GREEN PARTY.
HE THEN LED THE GREEN PARTY FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE, CHOSE TO
LEAVE THE PARTY IN 2008.
LAST YEAR HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
PRESIDENCY AS AN INDEPENDENT
AND A VERY CLOSE ELECTION
AGAINST FAR RIGHT NATIONALISTS.
HE SIX -- SUCCESS WAS FOLLOWED
BY VICTORIES IN THE NETHERLANDS
AND FRANCE.
THEY ALSO DEFEATED BARRET
OPPONENTS.
>>> SOME OF YOU -- SOME VIEWED
THESE EVENTS AS SIGNALING THE
REVERSAL OF A NATIVIST TIDE IN
EUROPE.
AND AFFIRMATION OF THE
NATIONALISM THAT INSPIRED THE
EUROPEAN UNION'S FORMATION IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
OTHERS ARE LEFT SANGUINE ABOUT
THE MEANING OF THESE ELECTION
RESULTS.
SIDING THE NARROWNESS OF THE
VICTORIES, THE UNFOLDING
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BRICKS THAT
VOTE IN THE CONTINUING STRENGTH
OF NATIONALIST MEDICAL
MOVEMENTS.
THIS IS PIVOTAL IN AN UNCERTAIN
MOMENT FOR EUROPE.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THE TITLE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S TALK THIS
AFTERNOON, EU, AND EVER CLOSER
UNION IS ACTUATED WITH A?.
THE FUTURE OF EUROPE AND THE
EUROPEAN UNION IS A TOPIC THAT
DEMANDS OUR ATTENTION.
WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE
AS OUR GUEST A LEADER WHO IS
ONE OF THE PEOPLE DETERMINING
THAT FUTURE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING HIS
EXCELLENCY DR. ALEXANDER VAN
DER BELLEN, FEDERAL PRESIDENT
OF THE REPUBLIC OF AUSTRIA .[
APPLAUSE ]
>>> THANK YOU PROFESSOR LEE C.
BOLLINGER . GOOD AFTERNOON TO
ALL OF YOU GATHERED HERE.
IS A SPECIAL FEELING FOR ME TO
BE BACK ON STAGE AT UNIVERSITY.
SOMETIMES I MISS IT, I CAN TELL
YOU.
I WAS ABOUT 50 WHEN I CHANGED
HOUSE AND WENT INTO POLITICS.
WHETHER THAT WAS A GOOD IDEA IS
AN OPEN QUESTION.>> AS THE
PRESIDENT OF A SMALL OR MEDIUM-
SIZED COUNTRY WITHIN THE
EUROPEAN UNION I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE SOME OF MY REFLECTIONS,
OPINIONS, CONVICTIONS OF
EUROPE'S FUTURE ROLE IN THE
WORLD.
FOR CENTURY, EUROPE'S HISTORY
WAS ONE OF RECURRING CONFLICTS,
WAR ALL THE TIME.
IN FACT IT WAS NOT UNTIL WORLD
WAR II ENDED IN THE ABYSS OF
THE HOLOCAUST THAT THE
UNDERSTANDING MATURED IN
WESTERN EUROPE THAT ONLY PEACE
WILL BASH PEACEFUL COOPERATION
WOULD ALLOW EUROPE'S CITIES --
CITIZENS TO ENJOY A POSITIVE
PRESENT AND FUTURE. CLIMATE CHA
50 NATIONS ATTENDED THIS EVENT.
I THINK IT WAS A SUCCESS.
ALSO, IT WAS INTERESTING AT THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY MEETING OF THE
UNITED NATIONS TO NOTICE IN THE
OPENING SPEECH OF SECRETARY
GENERAL GET TEARS THAT SHOULD
GET TEARS BASH, CHANGE --
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS HIS FIRST
POINT.
PRESIDENT MACRON OF FRANCE
CHAIRED A HIGH-LEVEL MEETING
ALSO IN THE UNITED NATIONS
ABOUT, WHAT WAS THE OFFICIAL
TITLE?
TRYING TO CONSTRUCTS, DEVELOP A
GLOBAL COMPACT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND IN
PARTICULAR CLIMATE
PROTECTION.>> TODAY I AM JUST
COMING FROM A MEETING WITH THE
FORMER MAYOR BLOOMBERG AND HIS
ORGANIZATION.
AGAIN ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN THIS CASE FOCUSING WHAT CAN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DO, WHAT IS
THE ROLE OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
SPICA THIS IS JUST AN EXAMPLE
THAT SHOWS OUR FUTURE IN THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE LIES IN
CORPORATION.
NOT IN CONFRONTATION.
SPICA AT LEAST IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION, ALL THE MAJOR CHALLENGES
FLIGHTS, IMMIGRATION, CLIMATE
CHANGE, ENERGY POLICY,
UNEMPLOYMENT AND POVERTY, WAR
AND DISPLACEMENT, VIOLENCE AND
TERROR.
THE DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION, ALL
OF THESE ISSUES CANNOT BE
RESOLVED THROUGH A SINGLE
COUNTRY APPROACH.
SPICA ANOTHER EXAMPLE THAT
SHOWS THE NECESSITY OF
ORGANIZATION IN EUROPE IS A
POSSIBLE ABUSE OF MARKET POWER.
BY A HUGE FIRMS -- I AM THING
POSSIBLE -- LIKE GOOGLE,
MICROSOFT, APPLE, FACEBOOK AND
SO ON.
WHO IS ABLE TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THEM, BRING THEM TO COURT AND
FIND NEW RULES OF THE GAME?
THERE IS ONLY ONE INSTITUTION
THAT CAN DO THAT AND THAT IS
THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION.
THEY HAVE THE POWER TO KNOW THE
STRENGTHS TO DO SO FOR LIKE
THAT.
NO INDIVIDUAL COUNTRY BY ITSELF
COULD DO THAT.
CERTAINLY NOT AUSTRIA BUT
GERMANY FOR INSTANCE IS ALSO
NOT BIG ENOUGH.>>> LET ME ADD A
BIT OF A PATHETIC WORDS SPICA
THE EUROPEAN UNION IS NOT ONLY
AN ECONOMIC COMMUNITY.
IT IS I HOPE ALSO A COMMUNITY
OF VALUES.
OR I SHOULD SAY MORE EXACTLY IT
SHOULD BE A COMMUNITY OF
VALUES.
FORMING SORT OF A COMPASS TO
DETERMINE THE COURSE OF THE
JOURNEY APART FROM THE DETAILS
OF POLITICS OF EVERYDAY
POLITICS.
SPICA WITH THESE COMMON
EUROPEAN VALUES, I AM NOT SURE
-- I DON'T WANT TO SAY THESE
ARE PURELY EUROPEAN VALUES I'M
SURE WE SHARE THEM WITH MANY
PROBABLY WITH ALL OF YOU HERE
IN THIS ROOM.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE
UNIVERSAL.
VALUES LIKE LIBERTY, INSTEAD OF
FRATERNITY.
PERHAPS YOU CALL IT SOLIDARITY.
I WOULD ADD TOLERANCE, RESPECT,
EMPATHY.
AND ATTENTION TO OTHER PEOPLE'S
NEEDS.>> THESE ARE THINGS THAT
SHOULD NOT CHANGE WHEN SO MUCH
ELSE IS CHANGING THESE DAYS.
SPICA IT DID NOT HEAR MY
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN TO BE
OPENLY IN FAVOR OF HUMAN RIGHTS
AND THEIR DEFENSE.
I WANT TO LIVE IN EUROPE THAT
IS CHARACTERIZED BY RESPECT FOR
THOSE WHO THINK DIFFERENTLY,
WHO LOVE DIFFERENTLY, WHO LOOK
DIFFERENT AND SO ON.>> THERE
MANY OBSERVERS INCLUDING THOSE
IN THE U.S. THAT HAVE THE
IMPRESSION THE EU IS IN A
CRISIS.
AT ODDS WITH ITSELF, AND
COMPLETES AND THEY HAVE A
POINT.
YET, I WOULD LIKE TO REPLY,
WHEN 28 HIGHLY DEVELOPED
DEMOCRACIES HAVE TO FIND A
COMMON SCRIPT, A COMMON
POLITICAL STRUCTURE THAT'S
CANNOT BE EASY.
NOT EVERY DETAIL CAN REMAIN
UNCONTESTED.
THIS REACHING A CONSENSUS
WITHIN THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
NEVER SMOOTH SAILING AND HAS
NEVER BEEN.
HOWEVER, I AM OLD ENOUGH TO SEE
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS GONE
THROUGH MANY CRISES AND MOSTLY
IT HAS GROWN FROM THEM.
FOR INSTANCE, I REMEMBER
ECONOMIC CRISES IN THE 70s,
BEGINNING OF THE 80s.
WE HAD THE IMPRESSION THAT THE
EUROPEAN PROJECT WAS LOSING ITS
FOOTING.
WE CALL THIS ARTHUR SCLEROSIS..
EUROPE WAS CONSIDERED TO BE
ILL.
A COUPLE OF YEARS LATER, NOBODY
TALKED ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
SPICA THIS EXPERIENCE HAS FED
THE CONVICTION THAT EUROPEAN
INTEGRATION INSIDE -- IN SPITE
OF VARIOUS SET BACKS AT TIMES.
THIS INTEGRATION WILL CONTINUE
WITH A STRONG ELEVATION AND
CANNOT BE REVERSED.
MORE OR LESS LIKE A LAW OF
NATURE.
THIS IS LOOSE THINKING.
IT'S A NON SEQUITUR BECAUSE YOU
MAY OVERCOME 100 CRISES SAFELY
AND THE 101st IS DEADLY.>> NOW
COMING TO THE QUESTION IS THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND EVER CLOSER
UNION?
TO JUST SEE THE 101st CRISIS OR
IS ITS ALREADY BEHIND US?
SPICA IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU
LOOK AT IT?
IT IS TRUE THE EUROPEAN UNION
WAS LONG CONSIDERED TO BE A
VERY ATTRACTIVE CLUB.
THE MEMBER STATES ARE DIVIDED
OR HOW TO DEAL WITH THE REFUGEE
QUESTION.
SOME COUNTRIES ON THE EASTERN
SIDE WOULD RATHER NOT TAKE ANY
REFUGEES AT ALL.
ON THE OTHER HAND, GERMANY,
SWEDEN AND AUSTRIA TOOK IN MORE
THAN 1 MILLION IN 2015 ALONE.
MOST FROM SYRIA.
PRESENTLY, THEY HAVE THE
PROBLEM OF DEALING WITH
REFUGEES OR MIGRANTS FROM
AFRICA CROSSING THE OCEAN TO
ITALY.>> AND OF COURSE, BREXIT.
THE DECISION OF THE MAJORITY OF
THE BRITISH POPULATION IN FAVOR
OF BREXIT ADMIRABLY>> THIS OUT
OF ALL EUROPEAN UNIT DREAMS.
THIS WAS SOMETHING YOU COULD
SAY THAT CAME AS A SHOCK.
PERSONALLY, I CONSIDER BREXIT A
SERIOUS MISTAKE OF THE MAJORITY
OF THE BRITISH ISLES.
UNLESS THE DECISION IS TO BE
RESPECTED -- NONETHELESS, THE
DECISION IS TO BE RESPECTED.
I THINK THE EUROPEANS TAKE THE
PROJECT MORE SERIOUSLY THAN
BEFORE.
SUDDENLY, IT WAS OPEN, IT CAN
ACTUALLY HAPPEN THAT THE UNION
IS BREAKING APART.
MY EXPERIENCE DURING THE SHORT
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN THAT
LASTED FOR 14 MONTHS BEATING
AMERICAN STANDARDS CONCERNING
THE LENGTH OF TIME.
>> IT WAS DIFFICULT GOING
BEFORE THE BREXIT DECISION.
AFTER THE BREXIT IT WAS
DIFFERENT.
ESPECIALLY AMONG THE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
MY OPPONENTS, AFTER THE
DECISION BRIEFLY TOYED WITH THE
IDEA OF AUSTRIA LEAVING THE
EUROPEAN UNION BEFORE I REALIZE
THIS IS TOTALLY UNPOPULAR IN
AUSTRIA.
FOLLOWING THAT, THINK OF THE
FRENCH ELECTIONS.
THE PEOPLE IN FRANCE MIGHT WANT
ANOTHER CHANGE WITHIN EUROPE
BUT THEY DON'T WANT NO EUROPE.
REGARDLESS HOW DETAILED THE
ELECTIONS WILL GO IN GERMANY,
THEY'RE COMING SUNDAY, I AM
CONVINCED GERMANY WILL CONTINUE
ITS PRO-EUROPEAN COURSE WHICH
MAKES IT INTERESTING STARTING
POINT TO THE NEXT YEARS BECAUSE
THE FRENCH GERMAN ACCESS WAS
ALWAYS IMPORTANT.
EITHER WAY TO BRING NEW
MOMENTUM INTO THE PROCESS OR TO
BLOCK EVERYTHING.
>> AN INTERESTING SIGN OF THE
CHANGE OF MOOD WITHIN THEIR
EUROPEAN UNION ARE THE SPEECHES
BY THE PRESIDENTS OF THE
COMMISSION.
A YEAR AGO, IN HIS STATE OF THE
UNION SPEECH AT THE SAME TIME,
HIS SPEECH HAD A STRONG
PESSIMISTIC UNDERTONE.
EVERYTHING WAS GOING DOWN THE
DRAIN.
THIS YEAR, HE WAS A DIFFERENT
PERSON.
HIS SPEECH WAS FULL OF
OPTIMISM, HE MADE SEVERAL
INTERESTING POSITIONS REGARDING
THE INTEGRATION OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION AND HOW TO ADVANCE ITS.
OF COURSE, PROPOSITIONS
IMMEDIATELY CRITICIZED BY THE
MEMBER STATES OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION, HE WAS OPTIMISTIC ENOUGH
TO PROPOSE THEM TO MAKE CLEAR
STATEMENT.
>> WHAT MAKES ME PARTICULARLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THE EUROPEAN UNION ARE THE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
EVEN IN THE UK, IT TURNS OUT
THE MAJORITY OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE UK WERE IN FAVOR
OF STAYING, IN FAVOR OF
REMAINING WITHIN THE UNION.
THE PROBLEM WAS MANY DIDN'T
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY ENOUGH AND
DIDN'T VOTE.
THIS IS A MESSAGE FOR SOME OF
YOU PERHAPS ALSO.
IF YOU DO NOT USE YOUR VOTING
RIGHTS, THAT CAN LEAD TO A RUDE
AWAKENING AFTERWARDS WHEN IT'S
TOO LATE.
>> STILL IT'S GOOD TO SEE THEIR
ANXIOUS NOW, THEY ARE AFRAID OF
THE IMPACT OF BREXIT'S
CONCERNING THEIR OPPORTUNITIES,
EDUCATION POSSIBILITIES, CAREER
OPTIONS. THE IMPACT OF BREXIT'S
IN SHORT ON A FREE LIFE OF
STARTING TRAVELING AND WORKING
ALL OVER EUROPE.
SPICA THE KEY MESSAGE OF THE
YOUNGER GENERATION, THEY DO NOT
JUST BELIEVE IN EUROPE.
THEY DO NOT JUST HAVE HOPES.
THEY HAVE A EUROPEAN IDENTITY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT THING.
I WAS BORN IN VIENNA BUT I
CONSIDER MYSELF A TYROLEAN.
HOW MANY IDENTITIES DO I HAVE.
AND THE PERFECT EUROPEAN AND
AWAY.
YOU CROSS THE FORMAL BORDER,
THE TRILLIONS, THERE ARE
ITALIANS AND EUROPEANS.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEMS WITH
THEIR IDENTITIES.
THIS IS A PREJUDICE OF THE
OLDER GENERATION THAT YOU RUN
INTO IDENTITY PROBLEMS IN
MODERN EUROPE.
IF YOU LOOK AT RECENT SURVEYS
EVEN IN AUSTRIA, ONE PARTY
ALWAYS HAD THAT SHE HOW SHE
PICKED UP MEDICALLY?
FORGET THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
SURVEYED HAD A CLEARLY POSITIVE
AVID ATTITUDE AND ONLY 7%
RESPONDED THEY WERE DANCED
MENTORSHIP IN THE UNION AND AS
MANY AS 80% OF THE OTHER PEOPLE
FELT THEY WERE CERTAINLY EU
CITIZENS.
IN SOME CASES, THE OLDER
GENERATION WHICH I CONSIDER
MYSELF TO BE.
FOR A LONG TIME THE NATIONSTATE
WAS NORMALITY.
THIS IS NOT NORMALITY ANYMORE.
FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE, THE
EUROPEAN UNION WITH ALL ITS
FAULTS IS THEIR NATURAL HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT WAS NICE TO BE BACK IN
UNIVERSITY.
FROM TIME TO TIME, I NEED THAT.
NOW YOU CAN ASK ME ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO.
[ APPLAUSE ]>> THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING A LOT OF MATERIAL ON
OUR PLATE TO CHEW ON.
I'M SURE WE HAVE A LOT OF
STUDENT WHO WILL WANT TO COME
UP TO EITHER OF THESE TWO
MICROPHONES AND ASK QUESTIONS.
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE A BUNCH
OF AUSTRIAN STUDENTS IN THE
ROOM.
SINCE I LECTURE TO AUSTRIAN
STUDENTS WHO VISIT FROM VIENNA
EVERY YEAR, I KNOW THEY ARE
LIVELY AND WILL HAVE PLENTY TO
SAY.
AS THEY LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONES, I WANT TO MAKE ONE
PERSONAL OBSERVATION.
IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN WELCOMING YOU TO
COLUMBIA.
IN PART BECAUSE I WAS SO WARMLY
WELCOMED IN VIENNA TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN I ATTENDED A MEETING
ON THE 200th ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CONGRESS OF VIENNA.
SOME OF THE TOP OFFICIALS OF
THE CITY OF VIENNA CAME AND
ADDRESSED OUR MEETING.
THEY NOT ONLY WELCOMED US BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THEY
UNDERSCORED THEY WERE WELCOMING
THE REFUGEES THAT AT THAT TIME
WERE REACHING CRISIS
PROPORTIONS IN YOUR PART OF THE
WORLD.
ALSO, WE MET WITH PLENTY OF
REGULAR CITIZENS OF VIENNA WHO
WERE NOT ONLY HELPING THE
REFUGEES BUT ALSO WELCOMING
THEM INTO THEIR HOMES.
I FOUND THAT VERY
INSPIRATIONAL.
I THINK YOUR OWN BIOGRAPHY AND
WORK SPEAKS TO THAT AS WELL.
I APPRECIATE THE EXAMPLE YOU
SET FOR US.
WILL GO TO OUR PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE.
ASKED HER QUESTIONS DISTINCTLY
AND START OFF BY SAYING YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
YOUR SCHOOL OR DEPARTMENT.>> I
AM FROM AUSTRIA GRADUATING IN
2019.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING TODAY AT THE COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY AND THANK YOU FOR
STRESSING THE IMPORTANCE OF
STRONG EUROPEAN UNION.
POPULIST MOVEMENTS THAT
FRUSTRATE VOTERS ON ALL SIDES
OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
MY QUESTION IS, HOW CAN WE
ASSURE THAT'S COMMITMENTS AND
POLITICAL DECISION-MAKING AND
PARTICIPATION GETS LARGER
PARTICULARLY ON A GLOBAL AND
EUROPEAN LEVEL ACROSS CITIZENS?
>> UP TO ONE YEAR AGO, THERE
SEEM TO BE A CONSENSUS BETWEEN
POLITICIANS AND JOURNALISTS, AT
LEAST IN AUSTRIA AND GERMANY
AND THE NETHERLANDS.
FRANCE, I THINK.
THE NATIONALIST MOVEMENT IS
UNSTOPPABLE.
ONE YEAR LATER, IT'S OBVIOUS
THAT WASN'T TRUE.
IT WAS, HOW DO YOU SAY TO IN
ENGLISH.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT BEHAVIOR OF
PEOPLE ON THE STOCK MARKET,
IT'S HERD BEHAVIOR.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT EXISTS WITH
PEOPLE FROM THE MEDIA AND
POLITICIANS.
IF EVERYONE IS OF THIS OPINION,
IT MUST BE TRUE, BUT IT WASN'T.
I WOULD BE CAREFUL WITH THE
EXPRESSION POPULIST.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS USUALLY NOT DEFINED AT ALL.
WHO IS A POPULIST?
WAS MARTIN LUTHER A POPULIST
BECAUSE HE SAID YOU HAVE TO
LOOK IN GERMANY.
WHATEVER, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN.[ LAUGHTER ]PROFESSOR
MILLER IS IN PRINCETON JUST
PUBLISHED A LITTLE BOOK IN
GERMAN TRYING TO DEFINE WHAT HE
THINKS WHAT'S POPULIST MAY
MEAN.
HE DEFINES IT IN A WAY THAT
ONCE YOU SAY YOU AND YOU ALONE
REPRESENT THE POPULATION AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IS A MINORITY,
UNINTERESTING, IN MY CASE, I
WAS -- WHAT WAS I? A
REPRESENTATIVE. WE ARE PROUD TO
BE -- I PREFER TO TALK ABOUT
NATIONALISM, NOT POPULIST.
IT'S TRUE THAT IN SOME
COUNTRIES OF THE UNION WE HAVE
IRRITATING DEVELOPMENTS LIKE
WHAT IS THE ILLIBERAL SOCIETY
AND HUNGRY?
-- IN HUNGARY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THE EXECUTIVE POWER AND WHAT
THE POLISH GOVERNMENT WAS TO
CHANGE THE ROLE IN FAVOR OF THE
EXECUTIVE POWER.
THINGS LIKE THAT, YES.
NATIONALISTS, POLAND DOES NOT
WANT TO LEAVE THE UNION.
OTHER DOES HUNGARY.
THEY WANT TO STAY.
I DON'T KNOW OF A SINGLE MEMBER
HAS A SERIOUS MOVEMENT OF
EXITING THE UNION.
>> AT YOUR NEIGHBOR SWITZERLAND
HAS NEVER BEEN PART OF THE EU
AND FROM WHAT I GARNER MOST OF
THE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
PART OF THE EUROPEAN COMMUNITY
AND THEIR BEER INTEGRATED WITH
EUROPE.
IS THAT AN OPTION YOU'D BE
WILLING TO GIVE.
CAN THEY BE PART OF THE
ECONOMIC COMMUNITY WITHOUT
BEING PART OF THE EU?
>> YES.
IT COULD BE AN OPTION.
THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
SIGNALED THEY WOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER THAT.'S WHISTLING PAYS
INTO THE EUROPEAN UNION
PROJECT.
SWITZERLAND AND PRINCIPAL
ACCEPTS THE FREEDOMS INCLUDING
FREEDOM OF THE WORKING FORCE TO
MOVE.
THE GOVERNMENT SO FAR DOES NOT
ACCEPT FREE MOVEMENTS.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE ON THEIR
PROGRAM, NOT EVEN THE COMMON
MARKET.
I HOPE I'M NOT A FAIR.
THE PROBLEM OF THE NEGOTIATION,
THE MAIN GOVERNMENT SEEMS TO BE
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THE BRITISH
GOVERNMENT WANTS TO DO.
SWITZERLAND, TO COME BACK TO
YOUR QUESTION, COULD BE A
MODEL.
WHETHER THE BRITISH WANT TO, I
DON'T KNOW.>>> THANK YOU.
>> I AM ALSO FROM AUSTRIA.
I VERY MUCH IDENTIFY WITH THE
EUROPEAN IDENTITY DIMENSIONS.
MY QUESTION IS REGARDING MORE
OF A MONETARY INTEGRATION.
I WANT TO KNOW YOUR OPINION ON
A SHARED EUROPEAN DEBTS AND
WHAT YOU THINK THE EQUATION
COULD INCREASE SOCIAL COHESION
IN EUROPE?>> WHEN THE EURO WAS
INTRODUCED, I WAS ADVOCATING
IT'S WITH SEVERE RESERVATIONS
THAT I KEPT TO MYSELF.
THE ABDOMEN CURRENCY AREA, IT'S
OBVIOUS IT'S NOT AN OPTIMAL
CURRENCY ZONE.
IN THAT CASE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
EITHER STRONG MOBILITY WITHIN
THE WORKING FORCE WHICH I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE IN EUROPE.
OF COURSE INTELLECTUALLY, IF
YOU'RE FORMALLY WELL EDUCATED
AND HAVE PARTICLE EXPERIENCE,
THE EUROPEAN MARKET IS OPEN FOR
YOU.
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE, IT'S NOT
THAT EASY.
OR, YOU WOULD HAVE SOME KIND OF
INTERNAL FINANCIAL BALANCE
WITHIN THE STATE.
WE DO NOT HAVE THAT WITHIN THE
EU.
THE EURO FROM THE START HAD SOME
MISTAKES BY BIRTH IF YOU
TRANSLATE THAT VERBALLY.
WHICH DID NOT HINDER IT TO BE A
SUCCESS INTERNATIONALLY.
HOWEVER, IF YOU LOOK AT ITALY
AND GREECE, SOME COUNTRIES HAVE
DIFFICULTIES OF COPING WITH
COMMON CURRENCY.
AUSTRIA DOESN'T.
I ALWAYS SAY, SOMEWHAT
CYNICALLY, WE TRAINED FOR A
COMMON CURRENCY DECADES BEFORE
THE EURO WAS INTRODUCED.
THE SHILLING OF THE TIME WAS
BOUND TO THE DEVELOPMENT AND
EXCHANGE RATE OF THE DENMARK.
-- DEUTSCHMARK.
BUILDING THAT CHANGE FOR US WAS
A TELEPHONE NUMBER IN
FRANKFURT.
NOTHING ELSE.
IF YOU ARE NOT USED TO THAT, IF
THE EMPLOYEES UNION AND THE
LABOR UNIONS AND EMPLOYERS
UNIONS ARE NOT USED TO THAT
PARTICULAR REGIME, SOONER OR
LATER YOU GET DIFFICULTIES WITH
YOUR COMPETITIVENESS.
>> AGREES IS A VERY SPECIAL
CASE.
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE EURO ARE
NOT IS A SECONDARY QUESTION.
THEIR PROBLEMS ARE OF ANOTHER
QUALITY.>> DIDN'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION?
THE SHARED EUROPEAN DEBT.
YEARS AGO, EVEN YOGA -- EVEN
THE PRIME MINISTER OF
LUXEMBOURG, THE EUROPEAN
CONSERVATIVE PARTY, EVEN HE
ENDORSED HIS IDEAS SHARED
EUROPEAN DEBT WITH A SPECIAL
FORM OF RED BONDS AND
BLUEBONNETS.
LIABLE FOR THE EUROPEAN DEBT UP
TO 50%.
THE IDEA WAS GOOD.
BUT THE OPPOSITION WAS TOO
STRONG.
IN PARTICULAR, IN GERMANY, I'M
A REAL ADMIRER OF MRS. MERKEL
AS FAR AS THE EUROPEAN POLICY
IN GENERAL IS CONCERNED AND FOR
MANY OTHER THINGS.
THE FISCAL IDEAS OF FINANCE
MINISTER PART OF THE PROBLEM,
NOT OF THE SOLUTION IN THE LAST
10 YEARS.>>> THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR ALL OF YOUR
REMARKS.
I AM DOING THE SUSTAINABLE
FINANCE DEGREE HERE AT THE
EARTH INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING IT CLIMATE CHANGE A
NUMBER OF TIMES.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN THIS
COUNTRY, THAT TENDS NOT TO
OCCUR.
YOUR BIZ BEING SEEN AS TAKING A
LEADING ROLE ON ENSURING
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION
ANNOTATION GETS FUNDED AND
PROGRESSES.
IS FALLING SHORT OF WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN.
HOW DO YOU SEE, WHAT MECHANISMS
DO YOU SEE FOR ENCOURAGING MORE
AMBITION IN THE EU TO REACH
SOMETHING EVEN APPROACHING THE
LIMIT OF TWO DEGREES OF
WARMING.>> QUESTIONS LIKE THAT
USED TO BE CAUSE FOR SEVERE
DEPRESSION ON MY PART.
I STARTED DOING SEMINARS AND
LECTURES AT THE UNIVERSITY ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WHAT
ECONOMISTS THINK ABOUT IT.
IF ECONOMISTS REALIZE HERE'S A
SERIOUS PROBLEM, THE
CLIMATOLOGISTS MUST HAVE WORKED
ON IT 30 YEARS ALREADY.
30 YEARS NOW AND 30 MORE.
IT'S AT LEAST 60 YEARS SINCE
THE PHENOMENON IS KNOWN AND WE
HAVE DONE ALMOST NOTHING ABOUT
IT.
THAT WAS A DEPRESSIVE MESSAGE.
THE OPTIMISTIC MESSAGE IS,
BEFORE THE PARIS AGREEMENT,
ONLY A FEW PEOPLE BELIEVED
PARIS WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
2015.
IT DID MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I DO HOPE IT'S NOT ONLY IT'S
NOT ONLY HELP.
THIS IS A PRIME TOPIC ON THE
UNITED NATIONS LEVEL.
CONCERNING DEVELOPED COUNTRIES
AS WELL AS LESS-DEVELOPED WORK.
YOU ARE RIGHT OF COURSE THAT
IT'S VERY MUCH OF IT IS TAPER.
DECLARATIONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S REALLY
DONE, THE MESSAGE IS LESS CLEAR.
I THINK THE PEOPLE PERCEIVE IT
DIFFERENTLY, THE ATTITUDE HAS
CHANGED, THE ATTENTION HAS
CHANGED.
IT'S A MATTER FOR BLOOMBERG FOR
INSTANCE.
IT SAYS ON THE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL LEVEL, THERE'S A LOT
GOING ON IN THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
AMERICA I AM TOLD, MY ACHIEVE
TO FULFILL YOUR OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE PARIS ARRANGEMENT
EVEN IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T WANT IT TO.
BECAUSE OF THE ENGAGEMENTS ON
THE REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL.
>> WE ARE GETTING CLOSE TO THE
TIME WHEN WE NEED TO STOP.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WE WANT TO
HEAR SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TAKE
THREE MORE BASES AND QUESTIONS
AND A GROUP AND THEN GO BACK TO
PRESIDENT VAN DER BELLEN  TO
ANSWER WHATEVER IN THEIR WE
HAVE TIME FOR.
>> I AM EDGE OF -- I AM A
JUNIOR AT COLUMBIA.
WE HEARD YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
THE GREEN PARTY BUT LEFT IT TO
RUN AS AN INDEPENDENT.
I WOULD ASK WHETHER YOU THINK
PARTIES AND CANDIDATES ON THE
LEFT NEED TO TURN FOR THE TO
THE LEFT TOWARDS SOCIALISM OR
SOCIAL DEMOCRACY TYPE PLATFORMS
IN ORDER TO BEAT THE FAR RIGHT
IN WESTERN DEMOCRACIES?
>> THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT.
EVEN SHOOT THAT SHE MENTIONED A
COMMUNITY OF VALUES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL BE WHAT
EUROPE CAN DO AND WHAT IT'S
WILLING TO DO.
WHAT THE ROW THAT'S WHAT THE
ROLE OF NATIONAL GOVERNMENT IS.
>> AND LAST QUESTION OVER HERE.
APOLOGIES TO THE OTHERS WHO
DIDN'T GET IN.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, THANK YOU
FOR SPEAKING.
I'M A SENIOR AND COLUMBIA
COLLEGE.
EARLIER IN YOUR ADDRESS YOU
MENTIONED THE USABILITY ON TECH
SITES LIKE GOOGLE AND APPLE.
IN LIGHT OF ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND RECURRING
QUESTIONS OF CYBER SECURITY,
WHAT LEVEL OF INTEGRATION WITH
THE EU BE COMFORTABLE WITH AND
TACKLING ISSUES OF CYBER
SECURITY.
WHAT RISKS ARE INVOLVED IT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE EFFECTIVE?
>> IT IS TRUE I RAN AS AN
INDEPENDENT CANDIDATE BUT
EVERYBODY KNEW I HAD BEEN A
MEMBER OF APARTMENT FOR THE
GREEN PARTY.
EVERYBODY KNEW IN AUSTRIA I
HAVE BEEN A CHAIRMAN OF THE
GREEN PARTY FOR 11 YEARS AND SO
ON.
IT WAS MORE OF AN
ORGANIZATIONAL QUESTION.
IT WAS CLEAR, THE GREENS IN
AUSTRIA, AT BEST, IN THE LAST
20 OR 30 YEARS, YOU WOULD THINK
OF A 15% SHARE OF VOTES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO RUN FOR
51% OF THE VOTES.
IF YOU LOOK AT FRANCE, THE ROLE
OF PERSONALITIES IS GETTING
STRONGER AND STRONGER.
IT SEEMS LESS IMPORTANT THAN
EVER WAS.
THE WHOLE CLASS ORDERS ARE
VANISHING.
PEOPLE ARE ORIENTATING
THEMSELVES ACCORDING TO OTHER
RULES.
FOR INSTANCE, PERSONALITIES.>>
THIS SEEMS TO BE TRUE.
IF YOU LOOK AT SPECIFIC
COUNTRIES.
PARTY AFFILIATION SEEMS TO BE
VERY STRONG IN SOME.
VALUES, POLAND AND ECONOMIC
PERMISSION.
THE CONFLICT IS GOING ON.
IF EVER THE RULES CORRECTLY, IN
THE WORST CASE, THE MEMBER
STATE WHO DOES NOT FOLLOW THE
RULES THERE ARE NO VOTING
RIGHTS ANYMORE.
FOR THAT, YOU NEED UNANIMITY.
NOBODY SEEMS TO BELIEVE HUNGARY
WILL GO ALONG WITH SUCH A VOTE.
WE ARE NOT AT THIS STAGE IT.
YOU HAVE TO PRESENT ANOTHER
PROPOSAL AND WE WILL SEE IF
THAT WILL EASE THE CONFLICT
WITH THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION.
>> I AM NOT REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT CYBER SECURITY IF YOU
LIVE IN A COUNTRY WITH
DEMOCRATIC RULES OR THE RULE OF
LAW PREVAILS.
THE PROBLEM IS, HOW CAN YOU BE
SURE EVEN IF YOU LIVE AT THE
MOMENT IN SUCH A COUNTRY THAT
IT STAYS THAT WAY?>> RECENTLY I
MADE A REMARK TO A FRIEND OF
MINE THAT I FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
WHEN I REALIZE, FOR INSTANCE IN
CHINA, IF YOU TAKE -- YOU HAVE
AN APP WE CAN SEE THE NEXT
BICYCLE IS STANDING AND SO ON.
WE WILL EXPERIMENT WITH THAT IN
VIENNA ALSO.
SUDDENLY IT'S PART OF THE
INTERNET.
IT SHOW ME WHERE I WAS THE LAST
THREE DAYS.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT WAS
PART OF THE DATA.
FOR INSTANCE, THE IDEA THEY
HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
CUSTOMERS.
THEY CAN -- THEY HAVE A GOOD
BASIS FOR AN ESTIMATE, HOW
SOLVENT A CLIENT IS.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A VISA FOR
THE EUROPEAN AREA, DO WE RELY
ON THIS INFORMATION AS EUROPEAN
AUTHORITIES OR DO WE NOT?
IN PRINCIPLE, I THINK IT SEEMS
TO BE A SENSIBLE IDEA.
IT'S A PRIVATE FIRM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I WOULDN'T
EXCLUDE IT OUT OF HAND BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MARKET.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 300
IMPOSSIBLE TOURISTS COMING TO
THE EU.
THE EUROPEANS TRY THEIR HARDEST
TO GET A REAL SEPARATION
BETWEEN PRIVATE INFORMATION IS
ONLY FOR ME AND OTHER NATIONS
THAT ARE LESS -- ARE NOT SO
ANXIOUS ABOUT THE MISUSE OF
INFORMATION.
IN THAT RESPECT, I AM A
CONSERVATIVE.
FOR BETTER OR WORSE.>> THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS.
I HAVE TO SAY, YOU'RE SOMETHING
OF A HERO HERE PRECISELY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE AT STANDING AND
RESISTING THE HERD BEHAVIOR YOU
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR A CHANCE TO
LEARN FROM YOU.[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL THE BEST FOR YOUR
STUDIES.